look it's still absolute chaos but
things are a lot better because they've
been able to calm things down they've
put some uh sea cargo carriers over
there and uh these people are now being
processed they're coming through and the
british and american soldiers are
working together trying to keep these
khan these people here have a look
they've been they've been here for hours
it is absolutely boiling hot this is the
initial phases and people are either
being cooled through at times
they're telling them to you know bring
through papers and go to the soldiers
what you're seeing now is basically if
you go that way you're going to the
united states
and if you go that way you're going to
britain and that's what all this is
about they're trying to actually
separate the people of course there's
loads of other countries here as well
they've managed to get some control but
look at this right
look
there are thousands of people in here
thousands and this is just touching the
top of it because there's so many more
people outside who just haven't been
able to get here particularly for the
united states where there's more people
that are outside
kabul
do you know what's what's really
peculiar about this
you know there's another group this is
women and children you see this all the
time women and children just in huge
huge numbers
yes
they're getting the system done
yes
it's getting better
but you know
it feels more like a
a desperate
evacuation now
but at any given point you can just feel
the desperation it's it's quite
remarkable and i think everyone here
knows
you know
we're only days now days until the
flight stops